so etwas kennt man eigentlich nur als
science fiction horror ein roboter der
sich selbst zusammenfaltet und wieder
aufbaut in nahezu jeder beliebigen form
und so überall so ziemlich wirklich
überall hinkommt entwickelt wurde er von
einem forschungsteam vom massachusetts
institute of technology mrd er wächst
nicht nur genauso wie eine pflanze
sondern kann sich auch wieder so
zusammenlegen und sich zudem zu allen
seiten bewegen was er kann ist wirklich
mein blick zum science fiction story
spannen des seins videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los gehts richtig
willkommen das erinnert wirklich sehr an
den wachstumsprozess einer pflanze und
genau daran haben sich die expertinnen
und experten des massachusetts institute
of technology mit
bei der entwicklung ihres gros bots auch
orientieren seine gliedmaßen erinnere
nannten die einer fahrradkette
denn die einzigen die da können sich
zusammen und auseinander rollen jedes
einzelne glied des neuartigen roboters
verfügt über einen eigenen antrieb
sobald er sich als ganzes wie gewünscht
positioniert hat werden weitere
bewegungen blockiert und das jeweilige
kettenglied erstarrt quasi heißt also
der roboter kann viele verschiedene
zustände einnehmen kann sich ganz klein
machen alle möglichen zwischenstufen
einnehmen sich aber auch bis zu seiner
maximalen größe aufrichten außerdem
wächst der neu entwickelte roboter nicht
nur in die höhe sondern auch horizontal
doch dabei ist er nicht weiß sondern
fest genug um dinge zu greifen und zu
tragen oder um schrauben fest zu treten
ausgestattet werden kann er nicht nur
mit kameras sondern auch mit sensoren
oder weiteren technologischen zubehör
dazu dong xian der an der entwicklung
beteiligt war
er kann wachsen sich zurückziehen und
wieder in eine andere form wachsen und
sich so an seine umgebung anpassen und
so sind seine einsatzmöglichkeiten
wirklich vielfältig denn vor allem kann
es dort helfen wo menschen und auch
andere bisher entwickelte roboter nicht
hingelangen und so hat er seinen
vorgängern einiges voraus denn die
roboter die heutzutage in fabriken und
lagern eingesetzt werden brauchen viel
platz sie sind zwar in der lage um
material werkzeuge oder gegenstände von
einem ort zum anderen zu bringen
doch in engen räumen kommen sie an ihre
grenzen und auch das gezielte greifen um
beispielsweise an ware hinter einem
überfüllten regal zu gelangen
fällt den meisten bislang entwickelten
roboter schwer bisher werden sie für
spezielle aufgaben entworfen die sie
dann auch gut ausführen können doch im
fall der fälle müssen sie menschen zu
hilfe rufen
denn ihnen gelingt es einfach nicht sich
verschiedenen und einsatzorten aufgaben
anzupassen anders dagegen bei dem neu
entwickelten modell des m
nach angaben der forscher sind seine
einsatzmöglichkeiten wirklich vielfältig
beispielsweise wäre es für ihn kein
problem sich durch das antriebssystem
eines flugzeuges zu schlängeln und dann
an ort und stelle eine schraube fest
zudrehen
ebenso denkbar wäre sein einsatz an
einem auto wo er den kompletten
ölwechsel übernehmen könnte hierbei sind
bewegungen notwendig die in
verschiedenen höhen zu bewerkstelligen
sind und auch seitlich verrichtet werden
müssen der roboter könnte alle diese
aufgaben übernehmen und so zunächst die
ablassschraube herausdrehen und dann den
ölfilter austauschen auch das nachfüllen
des öls wäre für ihn keine schwierigkeit
doch auch in einem lager könnte der grow
bot wie in seiner erfinder und der
finderin nennen aufgaben übernehmen die
vorherigen modelle bei weitem nicht
gelungen sind das gezielte greifen von
ware aus einem hinteren regal wäre für
ihn beispielsweise keine herausforderung
wie gefährlich sind roboter anklicken
anschauen und tochter wurzeln den kanal
mit dem main floor faktor abonnieren bis
dann bleibt